I think one of the most important
findings in my book in my research is
that innovators fundamentally
misunderstand human capital as an asset
human capital as a resource
the majority of organizations that want
to innovate say we need to get
innovators we need to improve the
capabilities and competencies of our
employees we need to hire people who are
willing to take a chance at cetera at
such an be innovative and the whole
notion of you know our competitive
advantage in this post-industrial era is
that we have better human capital than
our competitors you know Google has
better people than iBM has better people
than Apple has better people than Amazon
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba I submit that's the
exact wrong way to look at it not that
it's wrong in the sense of false but
wrong in the way of being incomplete
what about your customers human capital
what about your clients human capital
the good Duncan experiment the thought
experiment I want people to get very
very serious consideration to is what if
we stop thinking of innovation as
something that's new and valuable that
we market and sell and what if we start
thinking about innovation as an
investment in the human capital
capabilities and competencies of our
customers yes
Henry Ford transformed the factory
production system with mass production
of the automobile the Model T the Model
A etc and everybody celebrates that as a
milestone in business history
I submit that economic historians
business historians marketers miss the
essential point Henry Ford didn't just
enable the mass production of
automobiles he facilitated the mass
creation of the human capital of driving
everybody drives it's an asset it
transforms markets it transforms
individual and organizational
capabilities why do we not spend as much
time focusing on the human capital and
adding value to the human capital of our
customers and our
as opposed to our employees I think
that's the essential innovation take
away how do our innovations transform
the human capital of our customers not
just the human capital of the people who
work for us and with us
the reason why I came up with the design
heuristic making customers better makes
better customers is because I wanted to
help innovative organizations filter and
prioritize their innovation investments
it's not enough to make your customer
better if you don't reap the benefits of
that investment
conversely if we're just making a better
customer that's exploitation so what
you're trying to do is align an
innovation investment that makes your
customer measurably better in some way
that matters to that customer in some
ways that matters for that client but at
the same time at the same time you're
making that customer more valuable to
themselves you're making them more
valuable to you by making them a better
customer you're making them a better
customer for you making customers better
makes better customers
you